Hello.
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to my humble tomato farm.
Everyone always asks me, why is the server called the tomato
farm?
Why are there farmers?
Why are there tomato wardens?
Well, you see children.
You see?
I have a tomato.
welcome to the farm children I
had to it's gonna be too high outside I had to take off my
skin suit real quick
ah yes
um my little tomatoes
It's still April 1st year!
Welcome to my farm, everyone.
Welcome.
As you see here, my children.
I harvest my children here.
And then we eat them.
Nice model.
Ah, yes.
The model is this?
Is it a new model?
Or was it inside me all of it?
on was inside me all along the chat.
Felicity, thank you for the five gift subs.
Thank you for donating to the tomato farm.
Thank you.
Then the inside you can't see you reach your file.
Felicity, thank you for contributing to the farm.
The internet, ah, thank you.
I'll just thank you, Victor, for the tier one, for not
months oh that's nine tomatoes right there nine tomato
children right there for you
I'm here for the point donkeys a v tomato confirmed vtuber I
would like to say v tomato tomats a v tomats oh shit is
there a country daily song though I don't know if there's a
country daily let me see let me see I can find country we
might have to we might have to change change up our our
daily song real quick I think I think we know what country
song we should do for our daily song today
I'll thank you so much for the fall and birthday welcome to
the tomato farm thank you thank you West Virginia well kiss
all right all right Felicity just for you Felicity everyone
close your eyes for the tomato kiss
take me home to the place I belong
Oh shit, okay, wait, wait, wait, this is gonna hurt me too.
Alright.
Welcome to Tomato Town.
Oh shit, I gotta flip you off too.
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
This doesn't work very well.
Wait, I can do this.
Guys, don't worry.
This will work.
Don't worry, guys.
Here we go.
This is for Sid.
Don't worry.
There we go.
Take me home to the place.
I belong.
Don't...
But it was not this kind of thing.
I'm disappointed, though.
Everyone keeps asking me, why is our server called a tomato
farm?
Now we know why.
Inside my skin suit was a tomato all along inside all of us
were tomats all along chat Why could they never catch up to
the tomato burglar they can't catch up to the Island Oh,
thank you everyone for coming to my uh vt burr tv tomato
West Virginia Country Mama.
Child, thank you so much for the follow.
Dad, thank you, thank you.
What's the backstory, though?
It is...
Oh, you guys want to see me dance?
Yeah.
Go to Virginia.
Mountain Mama.
Take me home.
Country Road.
oh country road we're gonna be home okay I like how I'm in
the apex category because this is supposed to be a quick
like five to ten minute joke but I'm still here I'm still
here I'm never leaving anyway guys so yeah it's so
technically it might be April 2nd to most people of the rest
of the world, but it's still April 1st year on West Coast.
So we're living our tomato life.
We're still going to live our tomato life.
This tomato work all day and night to earn the respect of
their parents.
And at their college graduation, they take the moment and
say, well, I guess I caught up.
Castle Life is leading me to my stream.
Over four hours here for it.
I wonder how much everyone's wanted to do this joke.
okay all right I I have a confession to make I've had this
model on standby for four months I didn't know what to do
with it and I was like oh shit wait April 1st I had this
model on standby for four months because I was like what if
I could do with this I was like oh shit I I didn't know what
to do if I just wanted I just wanted a tomato model but I
know I I didn't I couldn't think of any reason to use it for
she doesn't work for a month it plays off the other joke in
a multi-layered fashion exactly what do you mean joke this
is my true self right here are you what are you saying what
are you saying I've had the Discord server, I have the
tomato farm server for years.
We are out here harvesting my children for consumption.
And that is okay, farmers.
Remember, if you're, remember, by subbing to me, you become
a farmer.
You become a tomato farmer on a tomato farm.
Isn't that lovely, Chad?
Hi, Ruby.
You don't even have a nose.
as a tomato what am I gonna smell huh what am I gonna what
am I gonna smell I get
who is this tomato we were all tomatoes all along it's
honest work it ain't much but it's honest work chat what
happened to Doki what do you mean the was me online this was
inside my skin suit i just unzipped myself please don't eat
me so are the higher two tomato fires like managers over the
lower yes of course of course also thank you so much for the
follow again 10 kills on the board right now just wiped out
tomato town oh reject anime return to tomato exactly look at
these are my children right here these are my children i
don't know if you guys could see my children right here and
i'm gonna eat my children
delicious it's called survival the fittest they were strong
enough tomato tomato the air tomatoes are awesome people My
children were not strong enough, but don't worry, we can
make more.
We can harvest more of my children.
This is a turkey bird.
What do you mean?
This was me all along.
This was inside all of us all along.
We are all tomatoes in the inside.
How do you think tomatoes are grown, huh?
The Doki motto was very, we've also, like, do you know
tomatoes are from space?
Wait, what?
I didn't even know that.
Doki woke up and chose violence.
Tomato cannot doki.
Made it to be the same, Doki.
Maybe you look great even while makeup.
Love the natural look.
Thank you.
This is me wiping down all the human makeup and the human
suit.
I took it off, and here I am.
Where I thought you're...
all right guys all right so let's actually get into the apex
you know i think we've we we had our fun let me do a little
tomato dance real quick but but but but but but but happy
april fools i didn't i honestly i i came up with this like
in 30 to 40 minutes because i was like oh should i do
something for april 1st i was like oh shit yeah i have this
tomato model on standby for four like maybe this is a good
time to use it
why do I have a tomato model why do I not have a tomato
model excuse me I think everyone should have a tomato model
yeah why don't you have a tomato model excuse me what no we
are called a tomato farm for a reason You think there was no
real you think I did it out of Do you think like there was
no purpose to the tomato farm To my server?
Do you really think it was no purpose?
It's not like it still is here Alright guys I'm gonna go set
up for the actual apex stream I'll catch you guys later in
like uh Three minutes Two to three minutes And then we're
gonna pew pew pew.
We're gonna pew pew.
Let me put on my skin suit real quick chat.
I need a, I need to put on my skin suit guys real quick.
But yeah join the tomato farm to become tomato farmers.
Alright guys I'll be right back.
I'll be right back.
Hello.
I had to, it took me a while to zip back up the human suit
but it took a while.
to put it back on, but here we are.
Don't we, do not worry.
There's a tomato in all of us.
Do not worry.
Oh, thank you so much for the follow.
Laz and Hinan.
Thank you, thank you.
How about my heart?
Thank you so much.
What happened to the real dokey?
Do not, what happened to the real dokey?
What do you mean?
This is the real dokey.
What do you, I, I, I feel like I just woke up from a, from a
dream I had at the tomato farm.
Man, it was crazy.
All right, let me go, go be it.
Put my streaming playlist on real quick.
And pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
With our dad and Wapik, our personal singer.
I feel like I'm being...
What do you mean?
What do you...
Does this face look like a liar to you?
Hey, Asala.
all right let's uh let me join the voice chat real quick
hello hello all right you guys ready to peep you i want to
get tomato dokey back
tomato dokey how about this how about this if we win this
game If we win a game, I'll swap to tomato form.
Every game we win, I'll play, I'll be a tomato dokey.
That's definitely the face of a con artist.
Anyone who is late to the stream will have miscellaneous
life-changing experience.
Yeah, all right.
We need to win a lot.
I'll send him a tomato redeemed after the stream, too, for
the next year.
And then, hmm, unfortunate if I suddenly die.
Hmm, we'll be very unfortunate, guys.
Imagine the power boosted from the choosing tomato firm.
Tomatoes coming back.
Bug!
Mabel's boss actually heard beer tomato head confirmed.
Wait, have you ever seen hair on tomatoes?
Gosh!
Or maybe underneath this hat is a tomato stem.
We'll never know.
What is this tomato dough?
I don't understand.
You'll see one day.
Don't worry.
Where's Oswald?
Neighbors and me.
We will never know.
We will never know what's underneath this hat.
A tomato stem?
Or is it actually just a bald spot?
We'll never know.
You'll know when you're older.
Alright, alright.
so every win every win will get you a game of tomato of
tomato me so so it'll be very unfortunate if i if i run at
people with no armor very unfortunate indeed
maybe it's both all right this is a we're gonna sweat so
hard we're gonna make two swimming pools guys unless i'm
lying There's going to be a short stream today too, because
I'm sort of a bit tired, but I had to do this.
Getting free to do damage, 20 plus bomb tomato form game.
Where the fuck am I dropping?
I'm already missing out.
Do you sweat tomato juice?
Hmm.
All this tomato lore that we will find out on April 16th?
I don't even know my own lore date.
that I have the lore stream.
I don't remember.
In two weeks, in two weeks.
We'll find all this out in two weeks.
There's like a team like there?
Question mark?
52, I don't even remember my own date.
I just remember it said like in two weeks.
All right.
They're here.
The car's on the roof.
Oh, they think it's a car.
All right, I am gonna lose.
You guys will be fine, right?
I am not concerned about dying here.
What?
Iron is a safety base day after my birthday?
Wait, where did they go?
Over that way.
Oh, okay, I'm gonna take this car.
Oh, you know, I don't need that car going.
Forget that.
Oh, there's a guy right here.
Oh, what the fuck?
Don't worry, guys!
You can die if you want to, it's okay.
What the fuck, what is this?
Oh, is this, this is the April Fool's event?
You guys will be flying, right?
I'm looting.
Nope.
Oh, oh, okay, I'm coming over.
It's okay, I'm gonna stay far.
Oh, it is not okay anymore.
Oh my God, they're both cracked.
I don't have armor up here.
No, no.
Oh, he- No, he armor swapped.
Yeah, he armor swapped off me.
It's okay.
No game of...
That means I don't have to be tomato.
I'm sorry.
I have not played.
I think I do have- I think I played like 3D- They should
take the game that I should have.
I think I haven't really played the past like four days.
I think I played like like 40 minutes the past four days.
Um...
And I did not warm up before I set the tomats and before I
set up the tomato vtuber I did not warm up at all.
Hey terminal
So this is all no tomato no win
Tomato is all the way my new tomato vtuber heck yeah
There's gonna be a short stream too guys such as me I'm just
warning you in advance.
This will be a short stream I don't
know lately to be honest to be fair for you guys lately I've
been feeling the the burnout slowly creeping in on me only
because like uh because of all this like partner um are you
gonna throw the game away or no what do you mean also hi hi
Alice why are we dropping boys but yeah I haven't been like
feeling very like I have been feeling sort of the not coming
in lately because I haven't really had a break in a while
ever since like trying to push for uh push for party and
it's like such a vicious cycle because I have to reapply
every two weeks and it's like I can't just I can't like take
a break while I'm in that like weird area of reapplying
every two weeks so it's like I'm like in this weird
purgatory place all right where we going inside I I'm going
inside All right, we're all going inside WAPX I think
there's people on WAPX.
I'm not sure.
Yeah, yeah, there's a caustic as well.
It's okay.
I have do not loot my stuff How did you loot it faster than
me?
I was there first.
Stop looting my stuff.
Oh my god, wait, how did you get my blue armor?
I'm so confused.
Who are you?
Oh my god Poor guy What the fuck?
I'm so fucking confused.
I killed two.
Where's the call?
Inside?
Outside?
I heard someone inside.
Hey Logan!
I will mean when you're about to win, let the ice kill so
you won't become a debate.
There's people outside now.
I'm not going outside first.
Going on so they...
I tried to push here.
won't show up so love you all i love you too elizabeth yeah
yeah i'm with you i'm with you oh you're you guys are going
out okay all right i'll watch oh i totally didn't want
everything food arrived what did you get thing oh my god i'm
garbage you guys are okay right i'm looting one is here
right back oh i don't know i'm gonna say hello to i'm gonna
say hello to him oh there's people to my right i hear people
looting to my right right here in here we got one of them
there's also people yeah yeah this guy is right here yeah
Oh!
We tried Judy!
Holy fuck, he's inside.
I want to kill you.
Here.
Oh, I cracked the other.
I cracked the lifeline.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cracked the other.
I cracked the lifeline.
It's fine.
I have to reload.
He was cracked.
Yeah, okay.
There's one more.
Does it give me?
Oh, he's one.
Yeah.
There we go.
Look at that.
I believe you guys are a lot.
There's another team, by the way.
Yeah, I know.
I'm just looting.
Holy shit, that is, that sounds delicious though, not gonna
lie.
That sounds really good.
They're like fighting another squad.
Oh, what?
What they ran!
Don't hit us!
Are you kidding me?
They ran!
I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
That's where they are!
I'm leaving.
Oh, that's where they are!
That's where they are!
They were on there.
They were in there.
But it's so...
I am safe!
I'm safe!
Wait, wait.
Look at these sweaty people.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm so confused.
Oh, no.
They're following me.
I was safe for one second.
I will stay for one second.
I'm going to land into them.
We'll die together.
What's going to get there?
Did you just land in this?
More confusion?
I'm alive.
That's all I'm saying.
Freaks.
You're all freaks.
Take my shit.
Take all of them.
I don't even know what's going on in the moment.
What the fuck?
I don't know.
the book is going on also it's okay all right weeping i need
you to keep crawling oh please just keep crawling this is
our only hope no weeping no at least take his armor yeah i'm
gonna take his armor and go for me and run all right okay i
don't know about that though bye
I should have just left you.
I should have just left you to die.
You did it.
She's going to win us the game, okay?
I'm...
I hear them.
We...
I hear people.
I hear...
You're right.
I am a gamer They won't notice you I am a gamer I have
streamer Shut up
It's okay They will definitely notice me when I do this They
were missing too I left Goodbye Gamer is leaving Gamer is
leaving goodbye oh he's he's not pushing he's running away
till your slumps oh he's guarding his teammates that's so
cute I wish we had one of those I wish we oh this is looted
we might have a problem this entire area is looted you're
even holding back we might have a little problem because
this is looted there's a see i have a mass or i have a
spitfire i'm good i am so scared everyone i am so scared oh
arna is it on a nine by the way if you want it wapik i'm
trying to fight heals i got two batteries you want one yes i
would like oh wapik i don't know if that's a good idea yeah
no i mean they're gonna rev soon Oh, not another rebel.
I think it's the same rebel.
Yeah, let's go.
What?
Wapak, are you okay?
Are you okay, Wapak?
I am so far from you guys.
All right, all right, all right.
All right, I'm right.
Tomato Town is right behind you.
I have all, I have all, don't worry.
I alted.
They're queuing up.
They came out there on you, Ruth.
I alted, I alted.
Do not worry.
One hit to 50 on the Ruth.
okay i missed every shot do not worry do not worry i'm still
missing every single shot i did not hit a shot wait they're
getting shot at this is a new team yeah bye i have left
no no i have missed every single shot you know what do you
need i only have heavy all right we can we can we can third
this we can we third this like ring yeah as if we're great
players as if we're good players I'm just taking my energy
ammo oh my god what the fuck am I looking at what am I
looking at this
okay i can pick up i can pick him up the fuck oh yeah wait
okay no i'm leaving no no no they're resing but they're
gonna get the res off that's why i left look i got a blue
armor too is that the april fool thing yeah things just fall
out of the sky to give me loot yes and there's a mozambique
with more uh most golden mozambique and a golden okay we're
fine with some action top how am i still kill leader i'm
still kill leader in this game i'm gonna resin right here
i'm gonna resin right here why am i still kill leader second
time wepick second time this this time i'll help you hey
wepick do you believe me no no no even i don't believe then
i don't have you're right because i'm a gamer you're right
i'm working some from my ex-game naked and afraid it truly
is remember when you pick up it truly is i don't know how
i've lived this long chat i have like nothing like no yield
or anything i've i've been like scrounging up armors i've
just been like i've just been like stealing armors from
everyone
Alright, we'll be okay.
We'll be okay.
I'm guarding him.
Simply run.
Only the gods can survive the cluster, fuck.
Just like, uh, kindergarten.
This was looted.
There's a blue armor here for you.
I'm good.
I need, like, syringes.
I haven't found a single syringe.
I got a med kit for him.
Oh, I need that.
Oh, I found a med kit.
Found a gold heavy mug.
Oh my god.
How am I still kill leader?
All I've been doing is running.
I don't know what's sadder.
Oh, I need that.
There's another recipe I can use it.
You just run away, just leave.
That's why.
true it gets kills by simply existing oh wait I've not felt
laughing as if being dead you think I'd actually pick up
your mobile respawn beacon though I'll just run away I'll
use this for weapon that's to the dreams we haven't found
any other people since we started Are you ready?
I see people.
All right, Wapig, be careful.
Just flying into them.
Wapig, wait for us.
Wapig, just wait for us, Wapig!
Wait for us!
Is he stimming back?
Is he stimming back to us?
Where is he?
Where are they?
Well, there they are.
All right, let's go.
I'm ready to pick up your banners, guys.
He's right on the respawn beacon.
Even if MRB doesn't take inventory, he still doesn't take
it.
This is just a chance game of attack.
Might throw my on the respawn beacon, I guess.
He's right here.
Three times.
Three times the charm, guys.
Are there?
I'm almost here, guys.
Crofting.
I'm almost here.
That's not mine.
That is not mine.
I can't shoot them because they decided to start crofting,
so I can't see anything.
I can't.
Well, well, I might be well, I couldn't run from that holy
fuck like I'm stunned I'm like oh, that's the last guy.
That's the last guy.
Where is he?
Oh, I'm a gold Mozambique guys Where is the guy that's
chasing you?
Oh, he's just probably chasing me.
No, he's not.
I was trying to find him And oh, where do you see me team me
team.
Oh, I had a first 16.
Yeah You know, I'm just gonna run.
I'm just gonna run and heal.
I'm training people.
Oh, I cracked people to my left, to my left.
I cracked, like, a ton of people over here.
They're shooting each other.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're, like, super low.
I'm still kill leader.
Oh, my God.
There's two guys over there.
Oh my god, stop!
One for 30 up there.
Well, they're both cracked.
Yeah, they are.
This guy's not cracked, you liar.
ET wasn't cracked.
Well, there's only one guy.
It's only one guy, yeah.
He's right here, right here.
I think he's controller.
He like mega beams.
You're fine, you're amazing.
What the fuck?
What are these sevens though?
You got this!
Look at that.
Wait, they're res, they res.
I'm gonna leave you.
That's too nice to do this.
You have gold armor, gold armor, gold armor.
Gold armor?
Love you.
Where?
He's one, he's one, he's one, he's one.
Oh.
That guy's low, that guy's low.
Bap, bap.
You're solo though.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
There's another team shooting him.
No, that's Wapig.
No, there's a...
The other guys are resing, the other guys are resing.
There was a...
...scan from over there, but...
Weepix got this.
I don't have a secondary gun.
Oh, what the hell?
There he is.
Yeah.
He's infected.
Where?
He's low.
Oh, I'm gonna shout out to my left.
Oh, I got him.
I got him?
I don't know what the rage is.
Yeah, I don't have a secondary gun yet.
This is like my warm-up game, so I'm like, I don't know
where the wraith went.
She like, oh, there she is.
Is it a wraith?
Yeah, yeah, she got him.
I thought it was a low bow.
Oh, well.
Oh, my God.
How did we live?
What the fuck?
We did it.
Oh, here's the gold P20.
Where's the gold P2020?
Oh, did you take it?
Oh my god, look at all these...
Yeah, I'm gonna take this Mozam too.
Is the tomato power?
Yeah, there's one team left.
I've been a lot of them.
Where's the last team?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Thank you so much for the subscription!
Tier 1, thank you, thank you!
Can we get some Fortnite real quick?
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, by the way, I don't think Doki's healed up.
Oh shit!
I was not!
The one died.
Oh shit, no, this is...
Knock one of them.
I altered right side.
Oh.
This is my ult.
Here's the last guy.
Where is he?
What?
I can't see anything because someone threw a weapon.
Oh, me too.
I can't.
He's one though.
He's dead.
Oh, hey buddy.
No!
I didn't get him.
I didn't shoot him.
I didn't hit him.
You fuck.
I saw a P20.
I saw a P20 in my...
I did not hit him.
It's time to be a tomato.
No, it's time to be a tomato.
I should have just inted.
I should have picked you guys up.
Oh, it's tomato time.
It's tomato time.
Alright, that was a good first game, actually.
I am not playing Apex in so long.
I was whipping shots all around, but I guess it's time to be
a tomato.
Alright, guys.
Let me unzip my skin suit real quick.
chat let me let me unzip my skin suit for you guys
all right okay guys more frames more frames all right it's
tomato time
go let's look at go i have unzipped the skin suit it was
getting way too sweaty down there it was i can't do it
heartfelt i don't have it here i don't have i don't have it
set up for apex i'll do it later okay you know what what is
a nice tomato character guy
Welcome to the tomato farm.
I am a Tomata B-Tuber.
What did you do?
What do you mean?
We all have a tomato inside us.
Just unzip yourself, you liars.
Perfect rate timing.
This rate timing was impeccable.
This is the this the tomato within wrong rate stream tomato
What do you mean guys we all have a tomato inside of us I
just want to see me do a little shimmy To me a little to
make my dance at tomato town
Oh I'm dead mr.
tomato is dead This game is garbage.
What happened?
I clicked the on an R9 and here we go.
It's okay!
I'm alive!
Tomato is alive!
Do you want to fly?
I have no shields.
No shields.
I'm very confused and scared.
Why am I enjoying it exactly?
I'm farming damage.
Make it in a free.
That's all we are in these sites.
How much can you make the tomato dance?
I'll do it for free.
I'm this guy.
I'm this guy?
Okay, there we go.
Also, thank you so much for the Fall of Sydney and HN
expired.
Thank you, thank you, and Poseidon.
Thank you so much!
This tomato is gaming!
I'm a tomato gamer.
Wait, is everyone dead?
Where are they?
Yes.
Oh, okay, I was dancing.
What the fuck?
That's real gaming.
Yeah, but they...
It's like a mirage ball, basically.
I know.
This is gaming!
It's a true gaming experience.
I need...
I think they're like out salvage or something.
I'm gonna go K20.
I need like heels.
Our gamers unite.
I got these three times for you, one of you guys.
So do they just appear at random?
Make your tomato sweat so much you can fill.
Not one, but two last swimming pools.
I am coming over hey senor welcome to tomato gaming I am I
fucked up my looting oh I think it's so far already I was
confused that was how funny was with us why are you tomato
why am I not a tomato our servants call it a tomato farm for
a reason.
You guys, would you guys swim in a swimming pool?
That's just filled with tomato juice.
How the tomato juice was obtained.
I'll never tell.
Oh, thank you so much for the follow, Daniel.
Thank you.
So why isn't there a hammer point on the pit when you're
doing tomato, exactly.
Wait, did you kill all of them?
Oh, no, no, no.
What?
He didn't.
Yeah.
I got one bye I believe I don't have any heals I have to
fucking get armor real quick this shit is broken what the
fuck oh what the hell so this p20 is actually broken y'all
shed our skin seeds we're all tomatoes shed that tomato shed
that skin see what do you need skin for it's time to embrace
tomatoes
Are you ready to bomb the tomato from the he's my cousin
three times removed.
What the fuck is this?
25 damage per shot.
25 damage per shot this is gross.
The mage is just for shot tomato children.
Shit the skins embrace the tomat.
Oh wait what the fuck?
No, what the fuck?
I'm...
How dare you?
I am a tomato.
You're punched by a tomato.
See if you can get 8x7.
Did he have friends?
I have no idea.
I don't even...
Did I thirst him?
No, no, he died.
I wanted to go for this fight.
Why he's skin suit.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, nice.
at me i saw that no you didn't so i got 25 bullets and each
bullet does 25 damage to this what what is are you talking
about the p20 or the bosun gotta drink chug jugs of tomato
v8 to become a true gamer just eat your tomato children i'm
running double tweet p20 right now like it's so stupid it's
called survival the fittest 20 bomb every child every tomato
child i eat i get stronger
Wait, oh, I'm right.
He's hiding in the corner.
What the fuck?
How to shoot bad guys.
I'm so far.
That's it.
Dude, it is literally just above you.
There's one guy left.
Yeah, I got him.
Pop.
Dude, he's just shooting.
I just think he's onto the prime.
Can he get some part nights real quick?
Look how the pack is like getting rid of it out there.
Can he get some part nights real quick for us?
I know, I know.
And then he jumps down and dies.
there's another fucking guy just hiding in the corner like
what the fuck oh these corner sittings he wasn't batting
tomato emotes after partner of course you're gonna have
tomato emotes you think i'm an amateur i looked at him he's
just sitting there in r301 and he doesn't move after he shot
me like a normal human being no he's just sitting there it's
okay it's okay we're here now he's the bad man's gone now He
can't hurt you no more.
Don't get a toky's show you your tomato heart.
Your tomato children.
A toky's looking even higher than normal.
Oh, you like what you see, guys?
You like what you see?
Should I take off my humans suit more often?
Oh, I'm wearing my, why am I running into the zone?
I love my little shimmy, too.
I think that's my favorite part.
But I take off my skin suit.
I love the little shimmy I can do for you guys.
Maybe it'll be a tinier tornado.
Oh, shit.
That's where they are.
He's like...
He made a portal for his teammates.
Don't worry, guys!
Uh-huh.
Oh, what the fuck?
He's flush.
Don't worry, I have speed...
Oh, he hit me...
Whoa, he hit me!
That's illegal!
Here's him for me.
I don't like this.
So much mobility, all that flash?
Oh, but you forgot that blood in all games is just tomato
ketchup.
So technically you're killing your brethren.
So?
I eat my brethren too.
That's what they get.
They eat my tomato finisher.
I don't know.
See there, thanks.
It's called tomato juices.
Tomato seeds, camel, the cigarette's back.
Every tomato I consume might get stronger.
Feed your children, Simmy.
Become tomato, reduce it, boxy, come, bro.
Big Doki took a U-turn.
Well, it's not really a U-turn, more so of I'm right behind
you guys, way human dokey is a thief tomato dokey is a
cannibal why not both i can be both but you keep stimming of
course
how am i doing so well right now i am not paying attention
to my game
maybe as soon as i take out my skin suit i get stronger who
would have thought Ew, I guess I was getting too hot in
there.
Not people, right, aren't you, weapon?
Isn't that cute?
It's tomato.
We're at the needles and meatballs.
Crack one of them.
Wait, guys!
Horizon's crushed.
The Tomat is coming.
They're, like, over there.
Yeah, they're on the...
Wait.
Oh, this is a...
I was shooting the wrong guy.
Wait, I'm going to shot by a new team.
Am I right?
There's a new team.
There's a new team from my right.
I only have smiles.
Yeah, yeah, but there's a new team.
I'm ulting that team to the left.
He goes super slow.
Isn't it great that the level 21 with the Spitfire wins?
I don't know if they res, though.
He has a Spitfire.
I don't know.
I down one guy, but I think they res.
Oh, yep.
I downed him.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Oh, you killed the Spitfire.
Don't worry.
You're fine.
Yeah.
There we go.
It's a good Spitfire.
Truck this guy.
I thought he's Well, we're having a redo And now he has a
sheet It's just I'm showing my true form Okay, I'm queuing
up I'm going to rush my We tomato Exactly Isn't that how we
do Yeah, yeah, I'm coming with you guys I want to be safe
too I want to feel safe Oh, there's another team Yeah, yeah,
I downed one guy From one of the team Tomato kill leader The
power of tomato vtubers No
okay epic i'm going for it but yeah we're all tomatoes
everyone everyone wants some potatoes fake tomatoes
maybe i should become tomato and i'll truly be cracked at
apex what if we're all tomatoes all along though you just
gotta take off your skin suit guys or come work at my tomato
farm and then you will can be as good as apex like Take out
skin tears like the animal move where a character was
wearing weights and removes them.
You might want to grab a whacked mastage.
No, I'm fine.
The era of sea tubers is over.
It's vegetable tubers now!
Oh, that's the guy we killed.
I killed earlier.
I told you.
It's fine.
Give yourself a big and red one.
What?
Are we going to push that?
Yeah, sure.
All right, you go first.
Veggie tails were the...
the fruit vegetable too, Brace.
Oh, I hear them.
Oh, the armor's hooked on me?
Wow.
It's right here.
I don't know if they're going to come out.
Oh, yep.
Holy shit!
Oh!
He cheated!
Whoa!
No!
He's angry because I killed him last time.
He cheated.
take my shit
all right wapix gone wapix how dare they get how dare they
get high ground i live on the i grew from i can't reach that
i'm a busy part of the fruit gang god damn god damn fake
vegetables
I just gotta return.
Alright, Marino.
Alright, res me.
Res me.
Where?
Where's the tomato?
Hold on, okay, okay, okay.
We don't need WAPIC.
We can win this without him.
This thing's got people in their life.
God damn.
Feed me more.
Don't worry, chat.
You feed me more tomato children.
I'll get bigger.
It's hard living that rooted life of a vegetable.
Truly is.
But I gotta get ready.
Alright, Omni, thanks for hitting all of us.
Even though you were just lucky.
Thank you!
I hope you have a good night's rest.
Have a good street.
Thank you!
I hope you have a good night's rest, Omni.
Tornado capitalism to enhance the power exactly.
Why do you think I have a tomato farm?
I eat my children.
Only the strongest tomato can survive, exactly.
Survival of the fittest was created just for tomatoes like
me.
I'm gonna get armor real quick.
Alright, I have dumb guns right now.
Well, I have an RE-45.
It's alright.
To be cracked at APS need to pass a tomato trap!
eating all your brethren exactly all right i'm heading over
has no one has no squad died yet since i got res nope let's
just keep resing each other it's really weird whoa whoa we
whoa it's like that maybe the damage farm damage farm damage
farms in the pub oh wait no of course you oh wait never mind
everyone damage farms in the pub I've got it queued down and
it's like really low.
I'm just leading a bit more.
Do not worry.
I have nothing.
I'm going to take this.
Oh, it's Suki.
It's Suki-chan.
It's a full box down now.
All right, they're fighting.
Well, last two teams are fighting.
Yeah, take that box.
Take that box.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We gotta go to the last squad after.
Yeah.
Careful for your health.
Oh, shit, my health.
Yeah, yeah, I'm medkidding it in.
He go in first.
I'll clean up later.
Oh, they finished.
They finished.
I think it's a 1v.
It's a 2v3.
I'm almost there.
Oh, shit!
Wait, one's above.
One's above.
They're all above.
74 on the other.
Oh, no.
They're gonna heal.
Yeah, they're gonna heal.
What the fuck?
I don't have any.
I don't have any, uh...
Where- oh, they're gonna res tag me.
I fucking knew it.
Fuck you guys!
You're used to yourself, does that mean you'll keep going
back and not gain any size?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I would anyone eat themselves.
I have a farm.
I'm never gonna run out of food.
Well...
Looks like we lost.
Do I go back?
I guess I have to put back my skin suit on.
Because we didn't win.
Unfortunate.
Let me zip up my skin suit real quick, chat.
Hyo.
Hey, guys.
Hey, everyone.
miss would I miss chat no wait true tomato form what do you
mean this is my true form what are you guys talking about
huh what are you guys talking about chat this is my true
form huh you miss nothing now you eat something this
is a turkey I know what you mean guys I've always been like
this what are you guys talking I have no idea what you're
talking about
there goes the tomato
what are you guys talking about chat I've always been like
this huh
who is spawn when I recognize nothing
what do you mean I've always been the dokyo I know the thief
right the thief that's for some reason owns a tomato farm um
because she has she has honest living nope she doesn't
consume her children i make an honest living selling
tomatoes where are you and what did you do to write tomato
all right
well looks like we need a win if we want to unzip the skins
oh well goodbye one of them all right i'm coming guys don't
worry do not worry
i'm almost there are you rising here oh i did it there's
armor here i think they're on the other side yeah i don't i
didn't get to kill why did
Oh, there he is.
Twitch.
There's people on me.
Rotating, rotating.
They're like here.
They're here, too.
On the outside.
On me as well.
I'm going to see if I can get them to...
60.
Clagged him.
Behind here.
They're like outside.
Oh, are you serious?
Alright.
Yeah, right here.
1 HP on this kit.
Peek me.
Oh, he didn't peek.
me he knew he's not fun
come on oh okay fuck you alright I'm coming to you guys nice
this teammate's right here with me is this a song of the
century here in the bag banana algae I'm trying to even know
what song he's played to be honest oh he's right here now
where are you running sir sir why are you running I think
he's going to get his banner Sir?
I hear him.
He's so dead.
Wait, he has no, he has teammates.
He has teammates?
He has friends?
above us it's a different team now how wait wait he had
purple armor didn't he yeah he did and now he doesn't how am
i looking at how does he where where does purple armor go on
my body wait did you did you have blue oh yeah it's on my
body i earned it oh shit there's a where is his friends I
don't know, but I'm going to get this golden archery or one
in this middle of here.
What are those?
And a golden armor.
Golden armor, too.
Will we ever find his friends?
And it doesn't pick up.
That's my favorite feature about this game.
Wait, I need...
Wait, this gold Mozan doesn't have a hop-up?
No, but it still does 500 damage.
Oh, shit, really?
Oh, wait, I hear people read this way.
The P20 doesn't have a hop-up, but it does 25.
damage for short yeah yeah cringe we only use gold mozems so
it's like hammer points without the hammer points i i'm so
lost where the other person is yeah i'm so lost where his
friends are i'm just living for the other squad we need give
us chat give me your strength so we can be reborn as a tome
so i can take off my
Every game we win, I take off the skin suit.
They're, like, above.
I have a map room.
I have a map room scan, my pick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going over now.
I'm going to the other squad.
Wait, you're going to the other squad?
Yeah, because they're fighting.
Oh, okay.
I guess I'll go over there.
I don't want to want me trees, so I'll just go, I guess.
I think it was great.
Yeah, I want to shoot.
Why not?
We consumed some tomato children.
No, I stopped shooting.
Fuck.
Yes.
Fluffy, yes.
Flutter seems to release the tomato.
Wow, I just can't aim.
Not yet tomato dokey yet.
Okay, by the time we get there.
Oh no!
You got killed by a TTVer!
They didn't swap my guns instead of just punched.
Is he up there?
No, I think you shot him from below.
Oh, yep, never mind.
Quacked him.
I ulted I hear the octane
What I know I'm sticking it stick it stick it stick it I got
it He's low yeah I'm gonna heal now.
Bye.
Darsit.
Darsit him.
He's coming.
He took the zip up.
He took the zip up Cracked the bloodhounds Do not worry,
sirs!
Wait, what?
Where did he go?
Where did his teammate go?
I guess he's, yeah, he's downstairs.
Yeah, he puts down there.
Yeah, I'm gonna loot.
Yeah, he's healing.
He's healing.
Or was that my shadow?
No, no, he's inside healing somewhere.
Woo, where are you?
He's somewhere here.
I'm like looking everywhere.
everywhere.
That is a Twitch streamer, yeah.
I'm over here trying to make friends and he just doesn't
want to make friends.
He does not.
He's crazy, that's why.
He's crazy.
Like, I look at him, tea bag, and then he's like, nope.
I shoot you.
You'll get friends eventually where I pick you.
You'll get friends eventually.
oh that that team was crazy though i can you get in the game
what server are you playing because any servers are are
usually populated like i'm not looking at them yeah but he's
like i'm bringing you down with me what is he gonna do stay
with you i was gonna let him live i don't think i don't i
think you want to just leave i think i was gonna i was not
gonna tell you guys about him i was like oh he's gone and
then like make sure he doesn't get discovered i have like uh
no i have only syringes in my fucking backpack oh here take
take three batteries i got three i need like shield cells
yeah it's two bats and four shield cells oh yeah i need that
please feed me yeah yeah
all the heals oh my is this so much since i've caught a
stream hey asses I am level 47 I'm level I don't even know
what level I am I've maxed out a long time ago I used to
play that just fine with my uh laptop yeah but like apex
required apex is like so heavy intensive like GPU and CPU
intensive is that a new level it is because uh the game came
out a while ago so hi flu the game came out a while ago so a
lot of people are like maxed out levels
on season eight now i don't know yeah you can be like high
level and still be garbage in it i've bumped into a lot of
level 500s who are not the best at this video but they're
having a good time and that's all that matters they're up
here oh i i hear them but no like um oh they're still
fighting One is flash.
Well, you got one in them.
I am.
I ca- Wapping, do not worry!
I'm not.
Do not worry, Wapping!
This is two squads.
Thank you.
Where's that caustic?
Oh, he's in here.
I cracked him.
He's cracked.
Yeah.
They're like to my right.
I altered the people to the right.
there's a rappel coming in rappel coming in he's dead but i
need i got the armor swap they're there don't worry i'm
cracking the people to the right it's only a solo right i
cracked these guys what where oh this is a different team
there's a team right here though flash on one of them right
um be careful the teams are right 50 on them 50 on them i'll
push with
I messed up my thermite.
Whop!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, what?
Where did he go?
Wait, where is this teammate?
Oh!
What the fuck?
Where is he?
Oh.
What the fuck?
Wait, I'm...
I'm blocking this.
What the fuck?
Who the fuck?
Hello?
Oh, I mean...
I need help.
He's one, he's one, he's one!
Ah!
Yeah, we're a bit fucked though.
I'm gonna drop down here.
I want to see him control with my body.
Maybe my entry just is in pause stream of just one PC.
No, it's possible, you need like a really good graphics card
and a really good CPU.
It's possible if you don't want...
Not really good in terms of GPU and CPU, but like...
Well, I have my model on, so I need like...
good shit for it but you and i get heavy frame drops because
i drop from 200 to 100.
um to the play to have fun yeah play to have fun all right
i'm i'm fully you get it they're up there right above us all
right that's unfortunate i'm taking some names why are they
oh well Either you pick them up, because I'm leaving.
Then mine can go from 60 to 50.
Ah, console, I see.
They just want you to follow.
Tries or Apex Team or a PS4 account.
Thank you, thank you.
They're here.
Oh, they're like camping.
I have heat chills.
Oh, I do not have heat chills.
Do you have heat chills?
Is that the doke bird?
It is.
This zone is okay, right?
Yeah, it's second.
I don't know, I just realized, I don't have Medkid, but
that's fine.
We can raise him...
We have to raise him here.
Wow.
I don't have a mobile recipe, can you?
Nope.
Maybe one of these freaks had one.
No, they did.
Come in, there is salvage.
They're here, they're here.
I hear them.
Wait, I think they're fighting.
Yeah, they're fighting.
To my left.
Two gold!
Thank you so much for the...
Two months tier, I can't, I'm English hard.
Two months tier one, thank you!
Can you get some park nights real quick?
Bradugal, thank you, thank you!
I'm just gonna go res.
Okay, I'm just looking for...
Yeah, because they're fighting right now over here.
All right.
Yeah, they're just like...
They're fighting right here.
I'm just trying to apex scene.
Don't you think you're so much of a follow?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it, thank you so much.
My games are just fine how the how the emphasis is not able
to play on my laptop.
I make 3D games.
It's just Apex is very not very optimized very well.
It's like it's like very unoptimized.
That's why a lot of people like play Apex but they don't
stream it because it's like your frames die very like you
get like very shit frames that you try to unless you have a
good PC setup.
What, like, even I, like...
I think I need... No, I'm good, yeah.
This isn't looted, so you should be okay here.
There's, like, loot here.
There's a blue arm here.
I'm coming over.
Knock one.
I am almost here.
Where's his teammate?
Down there.
I see him.
45 on the caustic I hear uh bloodhound.
I'm burning one of them Uh bloodhounds burning Oh shit, I
thought that was you That's last guy
There's like stuff for you here I had a spitfire.
I was okay
No, yeah, Apex run perfectly fine max and even while stream,
but you want to low extend stream.
Yeah, yeah, you just can't, it's very hard to run it with
stream stuff.
Wapak, you want to purple?
Nah, I want to shoot you guys next to me.
Last two teams are fighting, right?
Yeah.
I'm just trying to aim, Pax.
Oh no.
He pinged them Wapak so I can throw my ult?
Oh.
Well then, my ult is on them.
On me.
there smoke smoke them smoke them i smoked him yeah they're
running they're right oh they're on me what the fuck stop
dying they're on me don't meet on me i got one of them last
guy last guy last guy
where's the other team there okay let's go Is that the full
controller?
Aww, it is.
That's unlucky.
And they have double Spitfire.
Alright, let's just Res Wapik.
Wait, there's no more Res Beacons!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Here, yeah, yeah, I'm going to Map Room right now.
I can- I'll Resim my Resim.
Yeah, yeah.
I got- We got Resim!
Okay.
Wait, wait, you don't have to go.
I'll go Map Room and Resim, and then I'm ditching him after
that.
Just stay alive.
Try to push updates constantly.
Yeah, there's a lot of bugs in Apex that they haven't fixed
at all.
Like, the rank...
There's so many bugs in Apex that they haven't really fixed,
but they're just like, well, we're still making money.
That's all right.
I think it's not just Apex.
A lot of developers do that as long as they're still
making...
Oh, they're pushing Epic, I think.
I'm gonna smoke them.
You're getting landed over here.
I'm gonna close zone.
I'm me, I'm me.
Oh you want to fight?
Oh no, we're fucked then.
I don't want to fight because I just saw me.
Yeah, I'm fucked then.
I hit him for 55.
I got one of them, but...
Yeah, I'm self-rishing with gold backpacks.
Yeah, but I think they might curse you.
Wait, he's behind me?
What the fuck?
I'm trying to get back to you.
How is he behind me?
There's no sound.
I'm coming back.
I dropped down accidentally, so...
Oh, okay.
Well, I finished one of them.
Okay.
Always, I'm trying to destroy my x-packs.
Well, I can't see him, too.
I hit 75 on him.
Oh shit, wait, what the fuck?
I'm dead.
Wait, what?
I didn't know he was above me.
Oh.
Peek me.
Come on, I know you want to peek me.
Oh, he's not.
He's trying to...
Yeah, he got your armor slop.
I'm dead then.
Yeah.
He got your armor.
armor swap that was ah that was close that was close though
I was fucking fracking my name was really on point that game
which is nice that's all me bros look it's like how uh
fortnite uh caters very heavily to little children um to buy
their skins
It's like, it's not just Apex, it's every other AAA game
that can earn money.
Like how, you know, they keep making skins of, like, very,
very big streamers and be like, Hey guys, buy my skin.
And then, like, children, kids are like, Oh my God, you're
my favorite streamer!
I'm going to buy your skin!
And then, bam, we don't have to care about anything else.
I played Eggman for the first time yesterday and see Doki
play Serial.
now that I understand a little more about the game the seed
the zoom it's just wild because I can stream hot flying that
game looks amazing yeah it's just apex in general it's just
not optimized for for the thing and so I need like a very
powerful rig just not very powerful just a very good rig
just to stream apex and have my model on and also and also
be able to Pew Pew in Apex.
That's why you see a lot of YouTubers that just run PNG
because they rather just have good frames instead of instead
of like, you know, Pew Pew instead of like having the model
on.
Can't wait for tomato-dokie skin in Fortnite.
We almost got our tomato form back.
Also, thank you so much for the follow Pineapple.
Thank you so much for the follow Pineapple.
Thank you, I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna fly over to there now.
There was a team here, but they dipped off as soon as they
saw...
No, not anymore.
They saw the Pred Trails and were like, fuck that.
You guys need to see where they make the games more parable
to play on lower end PC.
Yeah, this is unfortunate.
Maybe I should be using my shitty AFR stream the game, but
play the game on my PC.
That might work.
Yeah, yeah.
I see that.
I'm gonna snipe that.
I just got sniped at by...
Okay Well, I can't do anything about that Well, okay, I
thought you were gonna be You know what it's alright It's
okay.
This might be dumb But it's okay.
It's not dumb.
It was so smart.
It was so smart
He's cracked Last guy's over here though.
Yeah, I'm just gonna back up.
No No, there's another team.
There's another team on us.
I have?
There's another team over here.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
That bubble disappeared.
It's working.
He doesn't know.
Idiot?
Alright.
I am safe.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I heard there was a lot of problems with the switch port.
Are you still alive?
Oh, what the?
fuck why is your body here what the fuck why are you here I
mean oh that's not hot oh there is too a squad that
redeployed to me oh
okay I'm dead I just got redeployed it's okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's what I'm doing bring them over they're still
looting my body anyway yeah bye oh my god where is that
other team you know fuck this I don't want to die to a
controller team I'm bye
I'm not letting them kill me.
No, you're saying it's too good to die under control of the
game.
Yes, I am.
Too much dignity.
God, I dash.
Hope everyone has a good day and don't eat too many other
tomato presents.
Can't stop me.
Oh, good night though.
I really, I really appreciate you stopping by hanging out
with us today.
Oh, you have a good rest of the night.
Thank you.
Hey Viva!
Yeah, I'm gonna stream for like, um, I think around like
three or so minutes.
And we're gonna call it here.
I told you guys it was gonna be a short stream today.
Hi, Juki!
Let's hope we get like another win.
So we can be our true selves.
Do you speak Japanese?
I do not.
I apologize.
I do know.
I'm very bad at Japanese.
I speak a lot of other languages, but Japanese isn't one of
them.
Learning languages is just very hard.
She's amazing in French.
Ah, bonjour!
No, I swear I'm actually decent at French.
Oh, Tokyo only speaks wee.
Can we get?
Nope, only wins.
Unfortunately not.
I speak English, French, Chinese, both Cantonese and
Mandarin.
And a bit of Korean, but not Japanese.
Japanese is a very, very, very hard language to learn.
I just I just need to find the time to learn it I need to
get like a tutor.
I think like the Japanese you have to get a tutor to learn
that language Just because there's so many rules and like so
many So yeah, but I grew up with Chinese though.
I grew up learning Chinese from My parents so so that was
fine, but like if you're like especially at such an old like
you know like old such a late age whoa i destroyed their
secret thingy
i do not know which one one uh let me last to us this is low
this guy's low this guy weapon behind you behind you low um
uh to actually learn Japanese you lived or use it yeah yeah
same with Chinese too same with Chinese I think if I had to
learn Chinese um now if I didn't know Chinese at all I'd
have to learn it now um I would be I would give up I would I
would give up
a tutor like I don't I think dual angle doesn't really help
in terms of like uh in terms of like actually like learning
learning uh learning learning and language I think like it's
better to just hire a tutor instead of like going to do dual
lingo because i think dual lingo is just like an extra bonus
thing that you can do for like you know just to brush it up
after your
lessons are you are you a chinese i'm canadian are you a
chinese i'm canadian you sound funny when said cantonese
This is
my second year living Japan.
I can only do casual conversational Japanese.
I'm struggling business Japanese.
Oh yeah, I heard like, I heard like even like if you're
like, even if you're like a fluent Japanese speaker, like
you're still learning too.
It's still hard for like even native speakers in Japan.
So thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I do appreciate.
Thank you so much.
I think I might be getting sick, but I hope you end on.
Oh, we're Take care of yourself, take care of yourself.
I hope, get better, get better soon.
Get better.
I always get confused with Chinese.
I kind of understand because Japanese, but it just confuses
me.
Chinese has so much shit in terms of kanji and in terms just
how...
A state of American.
No, no, it's a separate country.
America is the state of Canada.
I don't know if you guys know that.
I don't know.
bottom I Have oh you guys are inside there's a team right
there's two teams up here Why can't my dad have me learning
Latin or ancient Greek I can't cheat it Don't worry guys
Don't worry guys There's a team outside.
There's a team out.
There's no bringing them with you.
No, no, of course not No, I would never I don't know.
Is there any armor here?
Uh, on the box maybe.
Oh, I found one.
In fact, you don't know like a language and grammar rules
and...
I'm just right here.
Where?
Oh.
Oh shit, I'm getting shot by a different guy.
Where's your guy?
Oh, right here.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Nice.
Above us?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, yeah.
There's a guy heading to...
On me too.
Yeah, yeah.
This is like a...
I...
There's so many different teams here.
I don't know.
I might be dead.
Yeah.
Oh, this guy's cracked.
Oh, nice.
Okay, yeah, well, yeah.
Even English is very hard.
Yeah.
English speaker it's very very hard to like English is such
a difficult language
you shout brissey?
oh please have spank acid how dare you that's fucked up
that's fucked up I hope they kill you and I don't res you
because kingdom neighbor is too shiny
not right now though
English has like the dumbest rules too you know what yeah
fuck it I heard the damages a lot too okay I just think no
no Korean is one that uses language in the world to learn um
if you want to learn a new language other than like if you
you know if you only speak one language and you want to
learn a new language that's not Korean like I mean, I mean,
you want to learn a new language and you don't speak Korean.
Korean is actually one of the easiest languages to learn
right now.
Also, thank you so much for the follow, Matt.
I do appreciate it and your memory.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Where do we go?
Oh, I'm gonna follow.
Oh, okay.
Where in Korean was just like, yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that's why.
There you go, wait, it's a full team.
What?
They're just chilling.
How many over?
I wouldn't call it chilling.
Oh my god.
I got one of them.
I can't climb this.
I don't know if I'm safe though.
I was like, he's already a little fall.
I do appreciate it, thank you.
Knock one.
I'm gonna shield cell real quick and then help you.
I'm hanging over.
This is the last guy.
Crash.
Got him.
I was like, come here.
I heard a charge rifle team.
I was like, get over here.
Get old.
Woo!
Bye!
I leave.
I hide in house.
That wasn't even the crypto team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because like the emperor...
No, no, no, no.
I heard a crypto ult just then.
Because of, yeah, the emperor, the ruler of Korea backed...
I went to his grave.
I have no light ammo.
Does anyone have light ammo to spare?
no i have like zero like bullets why are you so good oh
thank you muster well that's not true i can't fix anymore
yeah i uh yeah i went to like his uh temple area to learn
more about his history but yeah they they purposely um made
the language very very easy to learn where is ray i almost
cracked him.
Octane cracked.
Okay, I'm gonna take the jump pad.
Where's his teammate?
Oh, right here.
Oh, he's dead.
Last guy's right here.
Hi, he's so dumb.
You must sniping me for some unknown reason.
My aim today is really good.
Which is surprising, because usually on stream it's not.
I tried learning Swedish.
I could have two but it doesn't seem hard compared to other
languages.
I think... Oh!
I think Swedish is very hard to learn in terms of speaking
Swedish.
Got one of them?
Oh shit, wait, what the fuck?
Dead.
That was good.
Pop!
I did nothing and that's fine.
I tried learning Swedish.
Thank you so much for the follow, pros.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you!
Now I think like, Swedish is very hard to pronounce.
Like I can't do a lot of like European languages because
European languages is very hard for me to pronounce in terms
of like tongue movements.
Cause like you gotta like move your tongue in a specific
way.
And I'm like I can't even roll my R's.
Like I can't do I can't roll my R's.
That was me attempting to roll my R's.
And you gotta be able to roll, you use the...
That's me rolling ours.
Oh,
those sounds like it's always a fault.
Thank you.
Say, well, I'll still roll your arms.
Alrighty, Bob.
The language is one of the hardest, like, languages is very
hard to learn, especially the older you get.
So sign that I'm almost buried, like, you gotta be like the
best, you know, you gotta learn young.
Cause the older you get, the harder it is to learn a
language.
Cause your brain is already developed.
Unless, I mean, my brain stopped developing after a certain,
after elementary school.
But, but.
Wait, where are they?
And last time I saw them, they went in the bunker.
They're in bunker?
I'm just gonna read a play over above then.
I'm going to Lifeline Package.
Lifeline Package?
Where?
Here?
My son said Malay's easy learning, and somehow I took 10
years learning the formal version of my mother tongue.
I still went to Lifeline Package because there was nothing
in the radar.
Here, right in front of me.
Crack one of them.
I hit smoking on the other.
I'm trying to get closer.
I'm getting closer to you.
Hey there.
Aha!
Cracked off team!
I'm getting dead.
Where's your teammate?
Huh?
Oh, he had a...
Oh.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
I'm alting?
I alting.
This is my alt.
Where are they?
Nothing.
Oh, there are two here.
We're dead.
I'm coming over.
Yay!
I did it!
I contributed.
I did it.
I contributed!
I get a participation award!
Hmm.
It's funny, it's weird how people shame you for knowing more
than one language.
Because it's like, like, why would you shame someone for
that?
It's like, it's like, look at this loser knowing not, look
at this loser knowing more than one language.
Wow!
I never understood people who do that.
it's like what do you mean look at people shame for yeah
people do people shame some like like like especially like
kids like oh my gosh little kids are so mean I hear stories
of like no it's like in especially you live in like a
predominantly English neighborhood you'll be like look at
this loser knowing more than one language.
Yeah, I've heard stories about it.
Like, one of my friends said that she doesn't like...
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
So she doesn't like speaking...
Like, because she knows, like, three languages, too.
40?
40 on the...
Because her parents are from...
Her parents are from Malaysia.
And she was, like, seeing how, like, her friends would,
like...
Wait, where are they?
I got his teammate.
Whoa!
I got
one person, so I don't know if this is...
There's two teams here.
There's two teams?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
I just thought I was going to stay.
Yeah, the other team is in here.
No, there's a guy right here.
One?
I stole that one so far.
No, but part of it is that I'm using is don't often need to
use the second language.
I really like the background music singer.
Yeah, yeah, they're all over there.
Right here, I see them.
They're right there.
Poor guy!
The last guy's over here, the last guy's further.
Last guy, oh, last guy!
If we win this, I'd be a tomato again!
Oh, they're both one.
I'm the third guy.
All right, so.
I altered them.
58 on one of them.
I hit 180 and 160.
You're fine.
They're like running because of my...
Yeah, we just died, otherwise.
Yeah, I'm done.
What the fuck?
Why is that...
I'm dead.
Oh, last...
I...
Two, two, two, two.
It's two, it's two, it's two.
It's two.
They're resing one guy.
The other guy is self-res.
This guy is self-res.
Self-res, self-res, right here.
Self-res, self-res.
He got it off.
He's running.
He's healing.
Just heal.
He's running.
Come here.
It's an octane.
You're a tomato.
I'm a tomato.
That did it.
Tomato.
time all right we're all right this is gonna be my last game
my tomato game will be my last game all right now to take
off my sweaty skin suit all right guys it's very back I need
to take off my skin suit real quick chat be right back
hello the tomato is back I've consumed my children for today
Tomato supremacy is here
Thank you so much Don't follow Gail, thank you, thank you
Here's our selling ketchup pieces I won't hide Where the
ketchup comes from It's from my kids
It's okay guys I'm just gonna go Go die Yes I swear at one
point you'll be an anime dude.
I don't like your emotes.
Mmm.
It's time.
It's tomato.
It's time to do a tomato dance too.
Time to dance too.
No,
you guys help me harvest my children.
That's why I have a farm.
And you are my farmers.
And my wardens.
Adios, adios!
Yes, the tomato shuffle.
The tomato shuffle.
I mean, that's my favorite.
Whoa.
Bro, I ironically want this Tomato Mara Orwell to see more
of it.
Tomato dodging bows, like, whoa!
You know, like, that video of, like, that grandpa, like,
dodging and moving?
Because when he's playing Overwatch, that's me when I play
Apex.
Woo!
Can't kill me if I dodge!
Zina, I think he's gonna follow.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you
Yeah, we're gonna have it don't worry.
We're gonna have a tomato model redeemed you not worry All
right, I'm worried because I only have a sentinel
Oh, I have the guns I I hate Are
you okay I'm not okay Oh my god, they're all they're all
very low they're all very low where's the rate where's the
octane wait what what the fuck what he was next to you yeah
you couldn't tell he's low he's low I put you said low I
don't know I'm a tomato I don't the tomato you can't you
can't trust me I'm ketchup I was not low in any world I was
so confused.
I didn't know where he was.
It brought you over.
They're trusted tomato.
I eat my children and you want to trust me?
This one tried to learn ISL.
That's time for like 20 and did...
Oh my gosh, that's a lot of language.
I'm a joke.
It's important to learn record time.
What do you mean?
Joke, I had this model for four months.
jokes about the tomato.
Oh,
thank you.
People who have never watched you are probably so happy.
They thought I'm like an actual tomato streamer.
Tomato Persian pog.
Has science gone too far?
I don't have an angle on this guy.
There you go.
he just forgot where I was no I think he got scared that I
shot him
so it's gone too far but they can go even further how far
can science go you know I'm gonna go extra scummy cart I'm
gonna get that spitfire in my hands it's time for extra scum
scum apex gamer why did they get better yeah we go out in
public about your skin suit I don't know.
Sometimes I want to go wild and like get buried in other
farms and steal their tomato children for my own.
You know, you know typical tomato things.
For season killing.
Are you my children?
Do you want Jesse?
I make my own angles.
Yeah, I steal other people's children.
That's why I go outside.
Oh, what?
Bullshit.
Oh, you wanted to steal that?
Was that it?
I pressed A on it.
The tomato lean enables.
My goodness.
The game was like, nah, mate.
Not only do I steal money, I steal other people's tomatoes.
There can only be one tomato farm.
Look at that tomato potty.
That is peak apex performance.
You're a fucking sunscreen.
oh i hear a shot above
i have no idea where they are but i heard a wherever that
pump master is no more baby showers it's a boy no it's a me
it's time to go in my belly ambassador and it's up w it's
like here it's a great time if all my children's dream is to
be in my belly so I can get stronger in tomato we did trust
exactly exactly Faye knows what's up oh there's a fucking
portal here yeah there's people that like below here they
jump padded on these people I jump padded on these people
Oh, new team, new team, new team!
Oh, Revolt.
Behind you, behind you, I have a new team behind you!
Oh, yeah, I've got stuck right here.
Oh, no.
Oh, I'm dead too.
Oh my gosh, I have to like extra run.
I jumped out of the way WAPIC, so I'm safe here.
Woo!
No, I'm not!
I am actually safe.
You're like a foot of the wood?
Yeah.
Because I got stuck.
No, fuck this.
Because I was sniping.
Oh, you're from damage?
I don't know, I'm almost down the guy.
There is like another team on me.
Well, that's right.
You're right, I'll survive that.
You don't know, I'm a tomato on the ground.
I'm just growing on the ground.
I don't know!
I'm a perfect camouflage!
The perfect- Whoa!
He knew!
No, he didn't!
What the fuck?
What's wrong with you?
Tomato hater!
There's a tomato hater!
Are you here?
It's not the perfect camouflage.
I got crushed.
I got killed by a hater.
You can catch him.
I got squashed.
What were the odds?
I thought you were in trouble.
down below
dude this guy this guy's just one guy he's just one yeah all
right pick my body up and then other person res only fuck
are you okay i am back i just got the tomat tomato never
dies what do you mean there's still one squad here Alright,
I got to have that.
Alright, what?
The tomato never dies.
I shall be regrouped.
I shall regrow from the ground.
Watch me grow again.
Watch this.
Watch this, guys.
Watch it.
Woo.
inside there it is you may squish me we're just like okay
key someone ping me like the boxes groceries nutrition has
arrived you can never you can never fully squash a potato a
tomato a potato all right what do I get rid of all right
there we go two things are known in life streamers never
dying they don't never dies exactly yeah I need to get this
car mine and then so many gold items too
accidentally I have returned my seeds on the ground has
regrown a tomato I never die someone's been over here all
right I'm heading back I don't see him
Look at that 400 That was probably 400 damage I'm a 12 I'm a
true gamer
The tomato never dies
How does it feel to be immortal?
Have you ever seen a dead tomato?
I think not Only consume tomatoes
Crypto.
Last two teams.
There it is.
Oh yeah, they're on the hangar and somewhere the dungaloo.
The hangar?
What?
Yeah.
The thing, the 82 thing.
The diving board.
When people need to mail a piece, he lives out.
Exactly.
Watchtower.
I accept watchtower diving board is just weird.
No, it's a diving board.
Wait, so where are they?
Are we going here?
One is up here and one is down.
Oh, and I'm going where Wapik is because Wapik will die.
We don't.
I know.
Wapik instantly gets shot at.
Uh...
Oh, he jumped down one of them.
He's here.
Can you shoot him?
Wapik is down there.
Yeah, he's not.
I don't see him.
Fucking Ramfort?
Was it a clone?
I think so.
Yeah, I don't even see him.
That's a real one?
What the fuck?
I gotta hurry you got down of course you got down I'm almost
there I got galaxy burned also I got one of them I don't
know where his teammates are yeah yeah yeah at the back I'm
batting it
tomato freedom there's like a team that's like there's a guy
that has self-res in there hate milk yeah but the guy i
killed isn't dead they're letting him live i don't think
they know there's another team in there i don't think they
went inside you didn't win inside yeah yeah because the guy
i killed is still alive oh now they know now they know i'm
just dressing i'm gonna want to okay okay okay At the end of
the day, and then...
Yeah, I'm just gonna goodbye.
Goodbye.
Wait, wait, wait.
The guy we killed earlier.
They're...
Wait, they're winning!
They're winning!
The team we were fighting is winning.
Oh, no, wait, sorry.
Big C.
Yeah.
Yes.
Big C is having some issues here.
They're rezzing.
I'm gonna do something dumb.
Alright, I left.
I'm down too, but the other team is res.
The other team's res.
The other team is fully res now though.
I fucked up one of them.
I beg you to leave the Super Soyo's at Devontokie.
Alright, they're still in there.
The two I down is still alive, so I think they're gonna res
again.
No, I don't have one, guys.
Alright.
Well, yeah, but she still had one team.
What are you shooting me for?
There's not one team.
Oh, yeah.
I did it!
I did this.
The tomato luck.
Oh, there's a heat shield.
They use heat shields.
What?
Tomato win!
Wow!
The Tomat Shats.
We did it again.
Alright, guys.
GG's.
That was my last.
game ggs hello desi the tomato force we have one again how
about we you know what you know what guys um i feel a little
generous today let me uh let me zoom in let me do a actual
goodbye let me do a real goodbye then for you guys just for
you why is you a tomato Why am I not?
We are at my humble tomato farm.
Oh, why am I not a tomato?
We're at a farm Shit, wait, this isn't it?
This is not the the song that we need to play for the tomato
Let me let me get some royal.
Whoa.
Hey guys, let me get some royalty-free some royalty-free
country songs real quick for us.
I
Thank you, ninja!
Thank you, ninja, for the $15 dick.
That's what Scooby-Doo, by the way.
Let me, uh, all right.
Farming, farming royalty-free.
Here you go.
That, this seems like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, wait,
wait.
There we go.
The pure.
Weird.
This is it.
All right, guys.
Thank you for coming to my tomato farm stream.
Thank you.
Oh, time to blow a kiss.
All right, Espenny.
Before I end it, let's give a kiss to Espenny real quick.
Everyone close your eyes.
This is a tomato kiss for Espenny.
Oh,
should I eat some children, some tomato children before I
go?
Chat.
Do I, do I eat?
All right, lucky for you guys.
Oh, shit.
All right, for Ruby real quick.
Let me hydrate real quick for this.
this just wiped out tomato town all right guys let me pick
some children up real uh real quick chat let me pick up let
me pick up some children off the ground real quick all right
all right which kid wants to be consumed huh oh there you
are good choice good choice Alright kids, you ready to go
in, go in tomato poppy's mouth?
Mmm.
Every bite I get stronger.
Why am I saying that?
Mmm.
Alright guys, guys, do not know if you two want to join the
tomato farm, just do exclamation point discord to join the
farm and if you're a subscriber you too if you subscribe you
can become a farmer you can be a tomato farmer at my tomato
farm to harvest my tomato children so i can get stronger i
hope you guys enjoyed today's stream i had a lot of fun
today i did i i had i had a lot of amita tomat god I hope
you guys had a great time, a great April 1st.
And I love you guys.
Thanks for always for it.
Thanks for always.
Thanks for always coming to hang out with me.
And I really do appreciate this stream.
I had a great time, guys.
A new little tomato dance.
Tomato shimmy before I go.
But yeah, I'll see you guys next stream.
We're going to have a tomato redeemed too.
So we could just, you know, take off my skin suit whenever I
want.
Whenever you guys redeem the points.
I'll take off my skin suit.
and be my true self in my tomato farm.
Alright guys, I'll see you guys next time.
Bye!